My name is KJ, and I am the CEO of WPS
A company founded in 1998
To provide an easier way for users to work.
We were the first company to offer mobile work tools in 2011.
Since the release of WPS Office on Mobile
The growth rate of its users is more than 300%.
Google Play has great impact and global reach
Helping to bring the number of active users to WPS Office
To 10 billion users on mobile devices in more than 200 countries.
And the innovative features of Android and our unique business experience
WPS Office was chosen as the best app for 2015.
We've also earned the title of Best Developer and the app is listed in the Editors' Picks list in the Google Play store
The number of app downloads has recently reached 100 million.
Google's ongoing innovations provide us with greater opportunities for success.
My name is Qingwang Zhang, I am a technology official at WPS.
We use a lot of users' opinions to improve our product.
The translation service provided by Developer Console has contributed
In our communication with users around the world without any language restrictions.
Take advantage of our store listing experiments
To see user preferences around the world
Let us choose the best screenshots and descriptions
Highlighting the features of each update on Google Play.
And by using in-app products in Google Play
We have managed to provide many value added services to users
We are no longer making huge profits.
Monthly demand is growing by 86.2%
Our monthly earnings improved by 61.9%.
My name is Dong Wang, I am the product manager at WPS.
Keeping up with the latest features and designs in Android
We have been able to achieve rapid growth in international markets.
WPS Office was the first Chinese application
Provides the ability to display content in multiple windows
After launching Android 7.0 Nougat officially.
This feature helps improve user productivity
And enable them to open or compare documents to compare them
And surf the Internet at once.
It also provides multidimensional design guidelines
A more intuitive interface for our product
Which in turn contributed to WPS success among users.
With the growing number of WPS Office users
It is necessary to continue to adapt to the needs of users
This is possible with Google Play.
Thanks to innovations
And continued support from Google
The WPS Office application will evolve
To become a comprehensive solution to work tasks
For more users around the world.